las heridas siguen abiertas el 18 de
octubre se conmemoran dos años del
estallido social chileno la mayor crisis
en 31 años de democracia lo que comenzó
con un reclamo de estudiantes en contra
del aumento al precio del pasaje del
metro desencadenó en una ola de
protestas en contra de las desigualdades
en todo el país dejando una treintena de
muertos y más de 460 personas con daños
oculares
24 meses después chile se prepara para
la redacción de una nueva constitución
paritaria y participativa a través de
una convención constituyente esta nueva
constitución reemplazará a la actual que
fue redactada bajo la dictadura de
augusto pinochet
eso es hoy día yo es mantener el momento
de escribir como impugnación los 30 años
que nos llegó una vez en una transición
a la democracia que dejó pendientes
tantas cosas de derechos humanos y ahora
estas las vamos a poder hacer el órgano
constituyente liderado por la académica
mapuche elisa loncón tiene un año para
redactar la carta magna de los chilenos
que deberá ser ratificada en 2022 somos
muchos los que estamos trabajando con
convicción para que esa constitución ese
texto
a los chilenos sea una buena
construcción y que permite efectivamente
iniciar un periodo de convivencia
pacífica esta conmemoración llega cuando
chile atraviesa una fuerte inflación
debido a la pandemia y sufre una gran
inestabilidad política
el gobierno de sebastián piñera registra
un 20 por ciento de aprobación y ha sido
recientemente señalado en los papeles de
pandora lo que ha provocado algunas
protestas en santiago y el inicio de un
juicio político en el parlamento